foreign
good evening wherever the hell you are
in the world and welcome to Sidetrack
Yourself TV and Movie Channel where I'm
going live
just because I can
there might be an element of being bored
and having nothing else to do
but
hey why not and I do want to try to do
these lives a little bit more often
where I do just come and chat to you
guys get your opinion on a few things
because sometimes you know it's just me
telling you what I think
sometimes it might actually be a little
bit more fun to get what you think so
I might be joined by the other guys a
bit later I don't know because I didn't
tell them I was doing it
so just okay we'll see but in the
meantime get in the comments let's start
having a bit of a chat
[Music]
join a cup of tea just had a bit of my
son's
um brownies that he made I might be a
hopped up on sugar might go a bit crazy
today but um I wanted to have a chat
about Stargate anyway
because there's been a few people's
opinions going around
um and a couple of videos basically
going around and I've done a couple of
videos talking about it the the fear
generally is that Stargate is going to
get ruined by Amazon Amazon can't help
themselves they they just they're awful
everything they do is awful and it's
going to be rubbish so
um let's have a bit of a chat about it
I'd love to know what you guys think
before we get stuck in
um I'm thinking
should I have a little bit of a recap
about how we've got from there to here
it's been a long time uh sorry a bit of
stack of information
um from when Amazon actually bought MGM
to now why is Stargate still not been
you know announced
remembering though that actually Amazon
haven't announced anything
they haven't denounced any big MGM
projects so we shouldn't really be
shocked that Stargate hasn't been
announced either
um
but where are we at where have we got to
a few of the names Amazon that I think
are interested in there's one person in
particular
we haven't spoken about before
um
Jessica
naughty but yeah okay
um we could start there because we're
gonna look Walker's gonna be brought up
today and gender swapping and things
gender swapping roles
to be a regular Sidetrack you'll know my
opinion on this
sometimes it works and sometimes it
doesn't but I will always have the
Battlestar Galactica star book
example the Katie Sackhoff came into
that role and kicked ass she was
brilliant and I thought she gave a
different spin on the character while
still like being star book
the reason why they did that though was
because Ronald D Moore realized they
needed to do something a bit different
that character because it had been done
to death you know like the good looking
little bit of a womanizer smoking cigars
you know a guy with a Death Wish
basically when it comes to actually
being a fighter pilot
and they thought look this character's
been done to death how do we make this a
little bit different
make him a woman now that wasn't done
because of why a lot of other
times it's been done
so in other times cup of tea has gone
cold sorry many Englishman if a cup of
tea goes cold it's like spilling beer I
have to go out and kill somebody if I if
I you know let T go cold
um other times it's been done
to get headlines
all right and it's not there's not a lot
of people think oh it's because of um
gender equality or some other not so
some some High
um purpose they think Studio Executives
do this it's not a lot of the time it's
because they want to get clicks they
want to get noticed so they will do
something to a major character
because they know people will notice and
they know they'll go nuts and they know
they will click and the same thing I
think the star book gender swap was done
genuinely
out of you know a desire to do something
different with the character and a
desire to do something that made a sense
for the character
and it worked
all the times has been done it hasn't at
no point was Katie sakhoff's version of
star book anything to do with the fact
that she was a woman really in lots of
ways if they didn't make a big deal
about it it's not like Ghostbusters with
boobs where they went absolutely nuts
for it it became the gender you know
became the big part of the story it just
worked
um
does it make sense for story sake or
just making headlines it makes sense
then great if they don't do it in MGM
I don't see any reason why MGM would
purposely do that because the government
so we're not having a reboot everything
I've been told from day one it's not
going to be a hard reboot so we will not
see
any recasting of any of these characters
they just won't be in it so that's
a bonus there as well they want to cover
up bad movies about TV shows
yeah
um
sometimes it's like distraction
technique like look over here look over
here look over here because they know
the right one's not great the store is
not great they've rushed it or whatever
so yeah that happens too
um any news on Rodman okay so this is
why I want to do these lives by the way
guys so you can get involved with a
little bit more throwing questions when
you think
um I have not heard any news about David
hula being approached about any Stargate
I have heard of coupler names
I've got a video coming in a few days
that I'm still trying to get to grips
with but it was something that I
mentioned a few days ago about oh sorry
a few months ago now about Robert
Carlisle was approached apparently but
we didn't know what for but apparently
you've been approached
I then made a joke about an SGU animated
movie or I said actually wouldn't
wouldn't that make sense
um I've actually got a video coming out
this week in a couple of days since I
get edited about what I would like to
see for the franchise and one of the
things I said was I wanted to do an
animated movie for the SGU conclusion
that sort of conversation actually
triggered a source that I haven't spoken
to in over a year to get in touch to me
and said you might actually be closer
than you think
so I might have accidentally
sort of come across something here
The Babylon 5 movie was produced
completely in secret nobody knew it had
been done
and I won't say any more than that just
now
but no I've heard no no approach for
David Hewlett I wish I had done because
you know
it was one of my favorite characters
um
what franchise Amazon on Modern work
Studios not destroyed it is their goal
and then I constantly that is that isn't
fair their goal is to make money and to
take all your money that's what their
goal is it's not to destroy franchises
uh they didn't destroy the expanse there
you go there's one uh
I haven't destroyed the boys that's a
brilliant show again they just haven't
destroyed it it's it's they're good
shows
um I didn't hate rings of power I know a
lot of people did hate things about
and they said oh you know mixed race
characters and then there's a black elf
and things like this I didn't care about
any of that
um the the little the the the little
fellas I can't remember what they're
called
um that Lenny Henry was one
um they were actually in the book and
they said in the book they said they
were darker skins so I don't prom that
my problem with rings of power is that
it was boring
they didn't get the pace right at all I
think they thought they were trying to
copy the rings of um the Lord of the
Rings movies in that pace and they just
didn't do a very good job of it it was
too slow for a TV series you know 10
hours it's hard to watch The Lord of the
Rings at that pace sometimes you know
that's like three hours long but 10
hours of television
they got the pacing way wrong
beautiful to watch fantastic near
cinematic quality but it was boring
um but no there
whole point of their existence is to
make money and to take your money that's
what they want to do and the best way to
do that is actually to make good
television
they don't always do that but if you
guys could tell me one
one Studio that's ever been able to
actually make non-stop quality
Television over and over again
they all struggle
um sell it who would you sell it to Kev
the only Studio I think at the moment
that's actually making
quality Television over quantity
and that I cannot tell you a single
thing they've done that's bad is Apple
now a lot of people hate Apple TV
because of the company and I don't want
against that I but if you go into just
like what actually do they produce for
Apple TV Plus
I can't tell you a bad show on there
they all seem to make really good
quality television so other than that
but the problem is Amazon think this and
rightfully so that Stargate is like the
second or third most valuable property
in the MGM
um stockpile I mean that you've got
obviously bond is their most valuable
then you've got um Rocky with the Creed
franchise locked in
um you've got
um then it's really a Stargate and then
obviously everything else really comes
behind it so they're not going to sell
their most valuable thing when they just
spent eight billion dollars paying for
it
hey Shelly hey Brett
I don't expect the company to put out
anything as usual work garbage please
just sell it
that's the problem isn't it that but
like I said who are you going to sell it
to
animated
I put out a quote I put out a poll this
morning basically saying look guys and
I'll see how this about it
how it's doing uh
um
so Matt's just asking me a question nope
um so tomorrow guys we're doing a video
on the 10 most bingeable TV series and
Matt was just asking me does it have to
be sci-fi and I'm like no it could be
whatever the hell you like so let's have
a quick look so if SGU is to come back
and the only way it was to come back is
if we had an animated movie
would you pay for it now there's a few
different ways they can do that but the
chances are would have to be in
cooperation with somebody else most
likely Warner Brothers because that's
how they do in The Lord of the Rings
cartoon with
so I asked I'm gonna look I'm live on
live
oh is that so
the other way Amazon would bring back an
issue conclusions an animated movie
would you buy the Blu-ray 36 of C say
hell yes 26 of you say hell no I will
not watch animation and 40 of you say
I'll watch it but I'll wait till it
comes out on you know like stream
service I already own or whatever a
freeway I can watch it that's after 656
votes
I can understand why people don't always
love animation but I think it's because
a lot of the time animation has been
done badly
and that's you know that's the problem
is when it's done rubbish the new
Babylon 5 movie premieres I think it's
tonight at San Diego Comic-Con
um that's the world premiere
everything I've seen about that looks
pretty good
um and at the end of the day it's the
only way they were going to get a
Babylon five
episode again
because several actors have died or
they're just 30 years old so they're
just not going to it's the only way we
were going to get like classic Babylon
5.
SGU animation thing I think has got
problems and I'm stepping on the toes of
video I haven't even filmed yet but the
reason why I think it's going to get
done is because it's cheaper to do
a lot of the actors might not be
available but you can get around because
you just use voice actors it's something
they can actually still be working on
now during the strikes they can still
actually be doing it because the
animators aren't going to strike so this
is something that could actually get to
us quite quickly
and it would be cheaper the main thing
being cheaper because SGU is a bit of a
Marmite show people either love it or
hate it or or actually to me I'm just a
little bit indifferent to it but um
so I think it's the only way we'll
actually get it
and you know two-thirds of you that's
really a split three ways isn't it a
third of you just like don't want it a
third of you like holy cow yeah and a
third of you are like I watch it but
only when it doesn't cost me any money
so I think there are big reasons why
it's going to be interesting for us to
do
a Stargate Universe animation and I
think we will see animated Stargate
because it's it's just popular lower
decks showed that this can be popular
look how crazy people went over Star
Trek Prodigy the Babylon 5 movie looks
like it's going to do well
um all of the DC movies animated movies
would add you know just regularly over
the last 20 years they've all done
pretty well
um so from a business point of view
they're good
um yeah I understand that Steve Jenkins
and I'll stay a clear of animated sci-fi
contact long dicks being one Babylon 5
will be a no for me too it's aimed at a
younger age group and loses the audience
all the audience just my opinion Steve
Jenkins I I'm going to disagree with
this Steve only that I don't think they
do aim at a younger audience anymore
Prodigy was specifically aimed at a
younger audience and I would say that's
actually one of the reasons why it
failed but lower decks isn't
they I think there's a whole Generation
Now of of men and and women as well that
do watch cartoons my kids don't watch
cartoons they never have done they watch
YouTube
I have the Cartoon Network for years and
I've touched it before but I suddenly
realized I was gonna watch it
I'm watching He-Man and stuff
um and I'm not the only one
Netflix did the He-man series
um by Kevin Smith and we can argue about
whether that was good or not all day but
um I like bits I hate to do this but
they very firmly aim that uh it wasn't
in the kids anyway it was very thinly
aimed at people like me that you know
with that wanted to watch it so I don't
I don't think they are and
um the new Babylon 5 movie is actually
rated as a 12.
so definitely not
um thing
and certainly HBO for Stargate
I don't think Warner Brothers can afford
it
uh uh but yes
another possibility is at the moment
um
there's
MGM and Amazon could make this for
somebody else or they could get somebody
else to make it for them so we've we
have had that conversation about maybe
Warner Brothers are going to partner it
doesn't look like that's gonna happen
now it looks like they're moving away
from that
um because it does look like Amazon are
planning to accelerate their plans to
make their own stuff and to take on some
more Studio space and actually make
their own stuff so it seems that
um
they might actually make themselves
so
MGM though could make it for somebody
else it could make up HBO they could
make it for somebody else
um yeah it really bad Brandon it just
really was slow going
um I disagree Grand Beams I waited and
watched all the rings of power episodes
back to back and it was enjoyable
wow
do you guys tell me this was it just an
expectations issue my rings of power
that we were expecting better and
expecting more and then maybe when we
didn't quite get what we expected people
went nuts or was it in part that we were
told it was rubbish so often before it
came out that then a lot of people just
just were looking for the problems
I found it I think I went into it that
opened my day I found the first couple
of episodes quite boring
and that was a problem at the end of the
day entertainment it's TV movies if
they're boring that's the biggest
Cardinal SIM for me
I would rather
um watch something like Fast and Furious
you know that's stupid car in space they
had to take out a satellite so they run
it over it was beyond stupid but on
there shoveling popcorn in my face
um this is so stupid the Transformers
movie and stuff because they're
entertaining and that's what they're
supposed to be right so
Kevin McKay agrees apple apple is trash
band and I don't understand that I can't
disagree with you more on that
the problem with apple is there's not
enough on it there's not enough content
they've gone for quality over quantity
but For All Mankind is excellent
um The Silo is excellent Ted lasso is
excellent they've done four or five
really really good movies even going
back to the Tom Hanks movie that really
kick-started the Greyhound is a
brilliant movie
um
they've they've done some really
excellent stuff they've got a variety of
things there the new
um uh Sagal
not that one the other one uh TV series
and um
Indiana Jones is in it
it's kind of lives brilliant
um and shrinked I think it's called it
really is an excellent TV show
um it's a bit slow going it's it's like
it is a bit like it's a comedy but it's
a slow burn comedy so it takes you a bit
while to get into but this is actually a
really really good show and I I say I
cannot tell you oh sorry Foundation if
you love conceptual sci-fi it's a little
bit again a little bit of a slow burn
sci-fi but they've really spent the
money on it they've made a beautiful TV
show they've really kept it quite you
know loyal to the actual content
material
I I don't think anybody else is really
doing TV quite as
effectively at the moment as apple is
um Netflix are doing some interesting
things at the moment I'm going to say
like the Sandman TV series Sandman TV
series feels like a show that should be
on
Apple for me in the way that it's been
done the way there's been loyally put
together so
um I think that's that's really good
uh uh
I wouldn't take an adult animated
opinion animated SGU fix
I would take I would take yeah Prime
stream so just an animation skills and
and to be honest you're not wrong but I
think
I think the thing there is that
it's that's how it used to be I think
there is a trend and I think it's been
slow going but if you think about like
all the um
manga stuff and you know all that sort
of thing that was you know cartoons and
entertainment really for adults it's
taken a long time for like Warner
Brothers to like catch up but they have
been doing it
um and now it just seems to be it could
be a way and I think if Babylon 5
succeeds
I think we'll see more of this I think
we could see
um I think Dave actually on the Facebook
group earlier said
um what about X-Files if we can't get
that back maybe David company and the
other stars would come back and do an
animated thing that because you remember
the actors instead of six months filming
it's a couple of days doing the voice
acting so if you've got a problem you've
got a project and no one else can help
maybe you could hire a bunch of
actresses to come and do voices
um but but you can do it way cheaper you
can do it way quicker you can do it
completely secretly like they do about
five and you can do it fast the you know
the actors can come in do their bit and
then it's just the animators locked in a
room
there are loads of projects that we
could see come back
the the car either can't get made I mean
you could go back to like really classic
stuff
um I keep getting asked about like Blake
seven and shows like that at least
classic sci-fi shows that people would
love to see Rebooted
and I was saying that again but then at
the same time you don't because like you
love the original so much like Andromeda
or something like that why not do an
animated one where you can make it look
very similar you could do it as if it's
an episode of the original show just
done now get a couple of the actors back
if they're still knocking around and if
not get voice actors or do a reasonable
impression and you know and crack on
um there's no reason why that couldn't
be done for loads of TV shows Nostalgia
is very popular there always will be
we've got a whole generation of people
like my age that would kill to see like
an Airwolf animated movie or something
and we'd watch it we would and it would
make money for the studios so yeah I
don't know
on Android's website there's eight
features and seventh on the list yeah
but I don't think it's done by
popularity
um it's done by franchises they own it
just happens they put Stargate in at
seven is is it Bond
um Rocky number one and two
I assume it's not done in alphabetical
order
um from my financial point of view when
Stargate was on
um TV so like 15 years ago
um Stargate was the second most valuable
franchise MGM owned at the time it was
the franchise that made them the most
money
um it is the original Stargate movie is
still the Eighth House grossing movie
MGM have ever made
um so there's that
um and uh Stargate is I think
the third or fourth most highly watched
Sci-Fi show worldwide
of any Sci-Fi show if you look at just
hours watched
so um
yeah it's still a very very valuable
commodity
cheeky sod
but yeah I think we can do better than
that
um
see now I know a lot of Star Wars fans
that love
the Stars I love our Star Wars fans will
say the only decent Star Wars since
Disney's took over has been the animated
stuff
I would argue as a Trekkie
that the best
Star Trek stuff has been the animated
stuff it's way better than most of the
crap we get uh
you've got strange new worlds
but I would argue that lower decks and
actually Prodigy is more Star Trek than
anything else I think with animation as
well because it's cheaper
um you can do more with it you can you
can do stuff that you can't do on a
sound stage
the actors can jump nine feet and blah
blah you can or you can have way more
interesting aliens because it doesn't
have to be a human being in makeup if
you do a CGI alien TV show that's
insanely expensive and I've animated you
know an animated movie it's just drawing
them so I mean there are certain things
with animation that you can just do that
they can't do on a live action but also
they can take risks they can't because
it's way cheaper to do there are risks
that you can do that you just wouldn't
do in a live action because they're
scattering and going this show costs 10
million quid it's you we can't do that
it'll upset somebody will only off all
you know oh I'm not sure about this
story you know so it's like death by
committee almost because I'm almost
running around trying not to upset
anyone with an animated show that only
cost 100 000 you know a few hundred
thousand dollars to produce
all of a sudden you're like yeah let's
do something let's let's go let's do
something a bit different let's do
something a bit like let's let's push
the barriers a little bit
so there are benefits to animate
the problem with that is
things like this ask yourself would you
rather have an animated Rodney as
likable as a human Rodney and that is a
big point you've got the
it's not as good in lots of ways the
only thing I would argue with animated
is though if it's that or nothing I'd
take animated and I think with the SGU
that's where I'm coming from I don't
think they're going to do a live action
conclusion to Stargate Universe and if
you want it I just don't I just don't
think it's gonna happen
but we could get an animated conclusion
Stargate Universe so if it's that or
nothing I'll take the animated that
that's that is where I'm coming from if
the option is this choice between a live
action movie conclusion to SGU or
animated I'm taking the live action all
day every day I much prefer it but I
don't think that's the choice
I don't think that is the option
um obviously we don't have an option at
all they'll just do what they want but I
don't I don't think that's even possible
so if it's animated enough then I'll
take the animated all day
um and I just think it's the only
practical way to do it as well so but I
would much prefer yes I would much
prefer I would much prefer a live action
all day every day because they are just
better and like you said they're just
paid for us
um
positive word of mouth before I dive in
I would say go into an open mind and
just give it a go
that's just me give it a go and then
it's Stargate this could probably be
first live-action Stargate this is oh
sorry this could be the first thing of
Stargate we get for like 15 years so I'm
watching it whatever happens it's kind
of start getting it Kevin
they've they've done hemo they've done
it and Netflix has done it but Netflix
did just announce today I've canceled
the live action human movie they were
going to do which I was very excited
about after spending 30 million quid on
development they've decided not to
bother that's going to be the first of
many things they decide not to bother
with so I'm just catching up through the
comments
so can voice actors still work yes
in some respects they can um but um a
lot of them won't
so
a lot of voice actors only do animated
and things like that so they will
continue to work but even some of those
are saying that they're not going to
because they don't want to cross the
picket lines
they have a different Union
To the Actors Guild even though a lot of
them will be in both because obviously a
lot of them will do both work so
um say
um I don't know say safe with the
Stargate series and they did bring rush
back
I very much doubt they would be able to
do the voices now but that's not the
rumor I'm hearing
the rumor I'm hearing is that this has
already been done
but I'm trying to confirm that so don't
take that anymore then big hand assault
and over the shoulder that's you know
like big pictures of
um so but the animators have got their
own
um and uh Guild as well so and they're
not on strike even though again some of
them are refusing to work in solidarity
with the actors guilds and the writer's
Guild so that's a lot what we're seeing
is it's like this solidarity thing when
they have different unions
um
the thing is with animation if if they'd
already done the voices which they tend
to do the voices first they storyboard
it then they do the voices and then they
animate because then the animation can
change depending on the inflections of
the actor so the actor to something a
little bit different with a line they
can you know they can do the animation
to the voice so that's what they tend to
do so if there was a Target Universe an
if big if
but if there was they may have done the
voices a few months ago
so that's why it's an interesting
possibility that's being uh
being raised
um
let's have a look yes
yeah Kev I'm not trying to do this a bit
more often make to be honest because I
quite like doing it it's chatting to you
guys it's getting your guys opinions the
whole thing about something like this
particular words is Amazon gonna kill it
I think your opinion is more important
than mine
so yeah let's do this a little bit more
often for Pete's sake 11.5 billion 1.5
billion I've missed something
um
Joe you won't see any of the great
original shows because they have men and
roles of authority and confidence and
this is not what they want to portray
anymore
that's just ah
let's see I'm in two minds about that
argument
because almost one side of my brain says
that people are just people and they're
creative types and they don't think like
that
but my other side of my brain knows
that a lot of executives are so
terrified of being accused
of being sexist or right or anything
else they're so terrified
um they are actually going out of their
way to
um
almost planned to every
in Vogue thing you know um or invoke all
these different agendas
um they have to have every single
demographic covered they have to you
know do all these things and the people
that shout woke a lot have a point a lot
of the time because executives are doing
it
um the transgender issue at the moment I
think
if a good actor is translating I don't
think it matters if they if they have
I've started watching Quantum Leap it's
finally come to the UK I downloaded the
first couple of episodes
um but I find it's actually finally on
Paramount plus here so I can watch a
whole series I'm about halfway through
I'm really enjoying actually the first
episode the pilot episode we've done
quite cheaply but after that they really
kicked in with the money once they
actually decided they were doing it and
it's quite good I'm quite enjoying it
the one major character in like at
Quantum Leap command
um she he I don't know if he or she he's
got a boy's name but he wears makeup and
stuff so it's like that he's ours you
know like see I don't understand these
things so just
kill me in advance
um
this person actually whose name I can't
remember was also in the sandland
um very good actor very likable actor I
don't care they're wearing lipstick I'm
just done
um so and they're they're an Indian Man
actor I do feel like though that
sometimes it's just done because they
want to
fit a demographic and they just want to
do everything else so
um
yeah I I I I really enjoy it I thought
it was really really good to honest
um
my biggest experience Amazon like Amazon
well we're talking about fitting
demographics and things
Amazon do still have a head of diversity
now a lot of Studios took on heads of
diversity
um
a lot of
Studios I started to sack them so Disney
I think recently got rid of theirs
um but this was the invoke thing to do a
few years ago as a head of diversity one
of the reasons they did it was though
actually because
um people like the Oscars started saying
you had to have an element of diversity
in a movie for it to be considered for
um the best picture
so they all of a sudden thought oh gosh
we're gonna have to have this diversity
and also things like the metoo movement
and everything else they decided to
realize that actually
for a century Hollywood has been sexist
racist it just has
and they need to change that so they I
think they over corrected and went too
far the other way
but that happened so I do actually think
there is an element of that popcorn
power that
they have
[Music]
um
tried very hard
to make sure
there is diverse assumingly possible
I I mean I remember watching there was a
guy talking about the X-Files reboot and
they the first thing they said was it's
going to be diverse it's gonna be
diverse
and I'm just there going
why why is that the first thing you're
mentioning
no this is going to be great if you're a
fan of X-Files you're gonna love this
and if you're a fan of mysteries and
conspiracy all this other stuff the
stuff that makes X-Files X-Files no the
first thing is literally the first thing
he says it's going to be diverse now I
know there was a big argument to say
that the X-Files originally was a
particularly the verse it was like they
had no color in it like you know the
argument about friends was also the same
there was no homosexuality no it was not
very diverse
um and I'm like okay fair enough good
point
but
shouldn't be the first thing you
mentioned that should be like okay we've
got this new show we're gonna think okay
okay it does have to represent come on
guys it does have to represent the
society it's set in so if you are set in
the TV show in Delhi we need to have
some Indian people in it you just do
um but if you represent if you do the
film episode in Philadelphia say where
there's a high black you know it's not
majority but a high black and
African-American population we need to
show that in the cast
you know it's just like let's actually
represent the society or the culture or
whatever that we're setting this in I
don't think it should represent
everybody it should represent what it is
um if you do a film Richard III
you're not going to have an openly gay
person in that film because if you're
openly gay in the 1600s in England
you were stung to death so it's not
right which is where the world was back
then so and there weren't many black
people in England in the 1300s whatever
it was so my English History is great by
the way did you say that I went for 1600
to 1300s because I generally don't know
when Richard was about so
ask you I don't know
um
so yeah I think it's got to represent
what it's supposed to be about you know
um
let's have a look I'd rather have this
in the canned ones well I'll try to do a
bit both
dump the Oscars generally speaking
if a movie wins an Oscar
it's crap it's boring generally speaking
I like the ones that win Oscars for like
best special effects and stuff I always
keep an open an ax on my hand they must
have done something a bit different so I
quite like that
um music score okay
um best picture genuinely is because
they've done something very Arty and I
don't care
um in the real life my job is quite
stressful I I work for social care I
work in mental health before that my my
real life job is is difficult
so when I watch TV at home I don't want
it to be gritty realistic but I actually
quite a gritty but I don't want to be
like hyper realistic like no it's my
entertainment I wanted to entertain me
um I don't want I want realism to a
point
um but if I'm watching sci-fi I don't
necessarily want to be realistic other
than I wanted to maybe you know
if it's fantasy if it goes too far but
even that's fine
um I wanted to entertain me though
so
I don't think it matters if a TV show is
too gritty I also think it's always
funny when they do like a hyper
realistic like murder mystery or
something and they ask for teen
everyone's everyone wanders around all
miserable and everything throughout the
thing and I'm like that's not realistic
I've worked in films where and and real
life situations where life is stressful
and the first thing British people do
when someone gets really stressful is
they start taking the piss and having a
laugh
so
Captain
gave man it's here again uh problem is
the good reboots is they genuinely get
canceled AKA Knight Rider
but now I saw the Knight Rider reboot it
was Bloody awful that was my memory of
it is it was it was it better than I
think
um
I I think you've got a point for that
the Knight Rider reboot was terrible
they did a Gordon a Flash Gordon reboot
that was terrible Harris give me a wave
when you're ready sir
um okay throw him in
um so yeah let's well we'll ask Harris
got he thinks of that I thought you said
you love Flash Gordon reboot
it was all what you talking like shut up
and you're too young fat you've only
been five hey I have no idea which one
you're talking about okay last time it
was awful uh have you ever can you
remember last time there was
a decent have we ever had a reboot
rather than a Revival that was actually
any good
Star Trek the Next Generation that would
be a reboot
um
I feel like there's something I just
can't it might take me a second to come
up with yeah
uh well I guess it's a Revival Everyone
likes the new night court right
yeah
it's a Revival though it's they've just
brought the show back that's right which
is the same writer
is the miniseries the same as the series
or no
the mini series was better than the
series but then it wandered off
Does it include it went a bit yeah
so it's no no it was a complete it was a
complete reimagining okay it was um
obviously the same basic story but they
yeah new actors knew everything because
actually the original Battlestar
Galactic was in the the early 80s late
70s early 80s yeah so uh so yeah it was
a completely new one but that's the only
one I can really think of anyway how are
you sir
I'm doing well
um
Saturday morning I didn't stay up too
too late but I had to get in my what we
do in the shadows and it's always sunny
for the week so I stayed up a little bit
but you know
uh I think you're looking forward to
this Monday for another very short
Syndicate syndicated comedy little
sci-fi kind of thing right
it looks static for Monday for Futurama
coming back Monday is it it's Monday I'm
so bummed
yeah I think yeah doctor Doctor Who was
um
they just continued that but it did stop
for ages it did stop for like a decade
and then they obviously brought it back
with their attendance but they brought
it back but yeah I think you're right
actually they did they did a better job
with it when it came back I think you're
probably right yeah when I say when I
look up reboots
oh man every time Captain Caveman thank
you so much Captain Caveman for your
contribution but every time you do I
have to go Captain
because it was my favorite cartoon when
I was a kid I loved it
I couldn't I couldn't watch him go over
couldn't watch it the the new one with
Lucas Till I like Lucas still but it did
not look good I was just sitting there
going to Richardson University
that's all my brain did for like and
that's such an interesting I think they
cast him wrong
you know I I I I didn't watch it but and
I like Lucas too it just didn't seem
like it was
MacGyver in a certain way I guess
yeah I don't know about three episodes
and I gave up
is
cool
um Sherlock was good does that count as
a reboot or just another reimagining I
guess I would argue that was just um
they've been doing it for years because
they just keep redoing Sherlock um
Sherlock Holmes and that was just
another version of it the Sherlock in
America that was really good the one
over here with um Benedict Cumberbatch
was brilliant
which the the American one are you
talking about guy riches the movies with
RDJ no no there was a TV series called
Sherlock
um what was it called yeah it's called
Sherlock no it's called Elementary it's
called Elementary and Lucy Liu playing
the female Sherlock and that was another
time when I actually really thought
actually that the gender swapping I
mentioned at the top of the show gender
swap and actually quite worked but they
did a really clever thing in that they
gender swapped
um Dr Moriarty
so they had the lady that was
um um the the one woman that's um
Sherlock Holmes loved
and they had that set up and she was
being attacked us up with the shoes very
very clever and then it switched it in
the episode and they went and we
realized she's Moriarty
oh man and but they did it so well it
really worked because actually you know
like the one you think about it the one
woman that Sherlock Holmes would love is
because it's equal
yeah yeah uh it was it was really good
Hawaii Five-O and Magnum P I have both
been excellent as well actually to be
fair I've liked them both
are those reboots or continuations
though yeah reboots okay okay
best reboots and everything that comes
up is like Batman and Superman and all
these things it's like technically sure
but that's just they just do it again
they just keep doing it over and over
and over again
as reboots you know
yeah well I mean with um the new
Superman movies coming out isn't it
they've actually he's actually quite so
we're gonna skip the origin story and I
well thank god we've seen it 90 times
what all that and I was really excited
that he said well that I guess
fillions casting as Guy Gardner is like
okay so there's no Peacemaker and
suicide characters it is a complete full
reboot
thankful I'm gonna keep my fingers
crossed Nathan Fillion is
honestly he's not going to be in the
flash much next season no The Flash so I
just saw him somebody
he's not going to be in in the rookie
much next season
I've never thought about it and it was
just like saying um because he actually
spoke to he actually knows Nathan
Fillion's age and that's how I got that
information about the Firefly reboot
Revival conversations
um so he was talking to the agent and
the engine was very sane the show's
called the rookie Nathan Philly's been
in the six years not the rookie anymore
and I'm like yeah of course it should
but anyway let's talk about Stargate
let's do it
hi I've been having a look at the people
in charge at Amazon so I I wanted to
have a think about
um is Stargate really going to get
ruined by Amazon and let's look at look
any Studio that you look at you're going
to list off some shows you love some
shows you hate Amazon have just have
spent a lot of money
they have
um
50 million dollars you know rings of
power of half how much of that was rings
of power yeah
lots and lots of money
um but but Netflix always spend loads of
money as well and they've bombed hard a
couple of times that's one of the
reasons why Netflix don't like telling
you what their viewing figures are
because they like to hide it when I
showed us really badly yeah
so
um Texas size water bottle there Harris
oh yes sir always gotta go to exercise
everything my Star Trek look available
at all good stores as long as that store
is ciderstruct.com I can put my
Sidetrack sticker on the mug
not a mug you know what I mean my giant
ass water bottle that's okay correct
we'll put it right here
cool as soon as you get here God it's
even harder to talk about pointing
difficult with the backwards inverse
whatever trying to find a place on the
mud or water bottle whatever it's called
good Lord
anyway
um I I just think
um yeah so yeah I was having a look at
other people like I say they do good
things here man in the High Castle
brilliant series
you know that was Netflix that was sorry
that was Amazon all the way yeah so yeah
they have good stuff they have bad stuff
they always spend money in a few places
trying to catch up with Netflix but
everybody's done that as well and Disney
I would say if you're going to look at
the people the studios that are guilty
of doing some clutter crap in the last
decade Disney Disney are making everyone
put shame you know if if I could have
two shows that I wanted to be good that
were that were not good that should have
been good out of the past just decade
that the first two that come to mind are
the National Treasure show and Willow
it's just like oh Willow how do you [__]
a willow like legitimately there's there
are pieces of greatness in there and
then it just I don't know what the
writers did every episode I like just
cut the season into four episodes if you
need if that's the only material you
have I don't know yeah
yeah
um yeah Kevin's saying he's not seen
that yet a man in High Castle definitely
watch it give it a go it's fascinating
and it's like it is high concept the
Germans won the war basically that's the
that's the concept
um
John I
tried
so hard to watch Willow and the couple
of problems I had with it
um Willow I've forgotten his name the uh
Warwick yeah
can't act for [__]
I mean it was or it was painful it was
just like
read your lines stop it looked like he
was oh it was just awful
um when he stopped
I think as the series went on he stopped
trying and he did get better towards the
end but early on I was paying just felt
more natural by the end
um expectations were too high
they were we were all you know but were
they too high or were they right where
they should be
for Lucas time to bring something back
like that maybe we expected too much
from the first series the first series
of these shows are always not great
they're throwing the second season
okay
only thing okay I guess the thing that
is easiest to compare to Willow which
raised the expectations as high as it
was I don't think it's necessarily 100
fair to compare it to but mentally
I was just thinking Dark Crystal the
whole time I was like I want this to be
like Dark Crystal like I want that fun
campy kind of 80s thing turned into
something like this amazing
was that the biggest problem with Willow
is that they didn't try to tap into the
Nostalgia of it they're just trying to
do a show and don't get me wrong it was
written badly from the beginning but
they didn't
they didn't tap into the Nostalgia
that's really popular they just tried to
make a show
that's a good point I think because the
nostalgic bits of it they literally like
just gloss over it's like oh it's for
this half of a scene it's definitely not
a full scene it's part of a scene and
then keep moving past it kind of deal
like I think a storyline with the queen
would have done a lot better
yeah maybe
um
just I'm just trying to read the
messages as we go back through and bring
back bad today God bring back bad why
not
um if you're gonna if you're gonna do it
invest in two seasons and try and give
them time to develop the problems and
things which is what they're going to do
with drinks of power whether you like it
or not you're getting five seasons of
that whether you're all right please no
I mean
what you might call it we were just
talking about Amazon and in their their
shows that are smaller I think tend to
be really like well acclaimed like man
in the High Castle I don't know if
they've had Bosch the entire time but
even the shows they've like revived and
saved are typically well rated and
reviewed from the people that watch it
might not be like the largest of
audiences but
marvelous Mazel Bosh man from High
Castle I feel like there's half a dozen
little other ones and those are all
supposed to be excellent and then you
get the big tip pull things the boys is
great I think Invincible is pretty good
and I I don't know if that's tent pole
just yet necessarily
but then you got our off is it to be
fair is that when they you know
yeah
um
okay well let's get into this is what I
wanted to talk about oh yeah Jennifer
salkey was uh actually was the podcast
brothers that did a video
um but they've got me riled up about
this
um and I've actually spoken to him about
it says and they genuinely believe what
they're saying um it wasn't they weren't
doing it for clicks they're genuinely
really passionate about this they don't
like a lot of things Jennifer salkey's
done so I had a look at her sort of
career she worked at NBC she was a head
of Universal Studios for years she was
head of NBC in fact and they were doing
Modern Family which ended up being the
most popular comedy series of that
generation something followed yeah
friends and
um she was in charge of when The
Blacklist came through she was in charge
of the good place which is one of I
think one of the cleverest shows of the
last few years
um
you know I think
she's had because you know where she
started a career though
okay I will I will give you one million
pounds if you could tell me where she
started Korean can I get a hint
of any variety
they did a lot of TV shows for like
teenagers in the early 90s and very
early naughties
um
and
it's really kicked off an entire
generation of real crap shows but they
were like reality TV
um but scripted
the first thing that comes to mind is CW
but I don't think it's that it was Aaron
spellings production company so he did
um 90210 and okay okay so
um Corey spelling is his daughter and
she was also a 902 owner yeah the other
things so that's why she started her
career
um her husband actually is in the
industry as well he's the head of um Fox
21 Television Studios
um
but Jennifer salkey is the head of
Amazon and MGM Studios
Mike Hopkins is the senior vice
president in charge of Prime Video
Amazon Studios free vmgm and MGM plus
he's worked at Sony before that and then
he worked at Hulu
he's the guy that's making most of these
big sort of like
business decisions
you know hunt all reality TV shows are
scripted yes absolutely
um
Aaron Spelling did the rental box no
isn't that that's a game
that's uh he did it's because the guy
that did battles and book Rogers also
did
Airwolf Knight Rider
oh you could have made you love Airwolf
so much yeah
uh wolf
let me just do it because I'm sure he's
the same guy and it ended each thing uh
Donald P balestaria he also did
um
once a week
he was a prolific writer in the 80s and
90s my God that man's typewriters
um I am I've sent a comment to JMS
yesterday because obviously the um
Babylon 5 movie gets um it's World
premiere tonight it's Sunday at
Comic-Con oh that's right yeah yeah it's
gonna be cool he's just signed a deal
and that he's going to be doing a lot of
comic book stories with um is it dark uh
a Dark Horse Dark Horse yeah and I'm
just like oh
have you got time for this if bubble of
five the reboot gets green lit is there
enough hours in the day or is this like
a little bit of an indication that maybe
that's not happening and he comes
straight back to me it's an indication
of nothing
um I would tell you if it was I've got
enough time but so JMS is obviously
pretty confident as well that he can
write like crazy
um but uh glennae Larson I always mix
yeah there you go what did I say
tunnelby palazzari I didn't know yeah I
think Lenny Larson and Donald P
balasario always get mixed up with
because they have because they did very
similar shows but you're right I was
glad it was Glennie Larson
um
but they were the two biggest at times
because like people like um Street Hawk
and all these shows they were all made
by that
um what was the stuntman show Lee Majors
that was one of them as well Arsenal
Donald P Belisario
I couldn't tell you but I like like some
Lee Majors I always like somebody Majors
oh yes I looking when he saved Santa
Claus it starts Scrooged
you've been a very good boy this year oh
yeah you have
um answer the question yes they will
probably not
um
so right so yeah I actually think Monica
Hopkins is the man we should be looking
at a lot more he was the guy that MGM
and Amazon
when they were merging MGM were led to
believe that there was going to be this
very slow phased integration between the
two companies
they were led to believe that MGM and
Lottery was going to just be given a
load of money and they were going to be
allowed to produce television shows
their way and they were going to be left
to it and Amazon were going to almost
act like a customer and that's what
they're allowed to believe
it was Mike Hopkins that then slammed a
ton of bricks on that immediately as
soon as the sale went through he was the
one that made the decision
he was the one that said
um no we're just going to absorb them he
was the one that went in and said from a
business point of view MGM is still a
mess
we're basically at MGM basically doesn't
exist there and that's down to Mike
Hopkins it's not down to Jennifer sulky
um
Mike Hopkins is still the head of all of
these things but he's I'm going to be
like slightly rude maybe and I I don't
believe this statement but I'm gonna
make it anyway
he doesn't get any grief because he has
a penis and Jennifer salki doesn't and
so she gets the crap
what's his technical job title again is
the senior vice president of Prime Video
Amazon Studios free vmgm and MGM plus so
here's the boss
yeah okay
well yeah no that's that's talking like
Iger for not necessarily Iger but that's
like Kathleen Kennedy for lucasfilm or
something like that but the the large
head not necessarily like the the
Kennedy or the yeah Mike Hopkins is more
like yoga yeah okay Butthead and and
selfies just head of TV and the head of
Amazon and MGM Studios okay okay just
the film then
yeah basically this the studio so what
they actually make okay okay
yeah I mean that that comes from higher
ups you want to talk about all this
Dragon going on and stuff at the moment
it's it comes from the studio and uh the
big Studio people are not necessarily in
the same mindset as the people that just
want to create things all the time uh
okay I like my money I'm from oil
country we like money but
It's gotta be there's art there's an art
form here and gotta allow the artist to
go and uh those Studio execs are the
ones that don't allow it all the time so
come on Hopkins
Hopkins yeah I think Lee Wilcox got a
point here that everyone thinks they're
an experience something they think
someone else did I could have as well I
honestly don't think Amazon and I think
we talked about this on a live video the
other week that Amazon tend to throw
money at creators
um I I'm not sure that's always a bad
thing they tend to trust creators a lot
of people said the Citadel was a load of
rubbish I actually thought it was okay I
stopped watching after unless I'm gonna
lie I'm lying I stopped watching my two
thirds away through I will watch the end
of it at some point but I did stop
watching it uh and I every time I mean
the wife go to bed and I said what do
you want to watch babe and she'll go uh
and nope no point just to go I really
want to watch the end of that Citadel
show that's not come up so um
and they spent a lot of money on it but
the Russo Brothers came knocking and
when we've got this idea for a TV show
and Jennifer saki trusted them enough to
give them 250 million dollars and I'm
like I would do that the Russo Brothers
come knocking my door I'm giving them
money
yeah
I mean with JD Payne and uh I think
Patrick McKay the the rings of power
guys just knocking on their door never
doing anything before and getting the
type of money they did it makes me want
to just write something and go up to
Jennifer salkey you know like hello I've
got a couple show ideas
Behind The Wheel of Time and the rings
of power
um I'm telling you as well the rings of
power decision was higher than Jennifer
salkey oh it had to be that's that's
amazing Mike Hopkins would have been
seriously involved in that position so
I'm not showing them Wheel of Time
I still haven't watched Wheel of Time me
either I've never read the books either
I I'm interested in reading the books
but that's not one that I'm like
beholden to reading first you know it
just hasn't grabbed me
yeah
yeah but I've never never watched it but
um black gives it off to give it a
chance at some point because people seem
so angry about it
um and I'm just not not interested in it
to be honest so I have to get a try some
point but but yeah I think Jennifer saki
probably was more involved in that but
she is supposed to be a manager she's
supposed to be the boss man at the end
of the day when something fails it does
come down to her at the end of the day
if it's something Amazon have produced
and don't forget Amazon don't always
produce a lot of these shows they're
produced by other people
buy it or they pick them up
um and that would be my copkins doing
that Jennifer sulky's head of the
studios
which you gotta remember as well
um one person I think is very
interesting though and it's not somebody
I've heard mentioned and like I said the
podcast guys didn't really talk about
her and stuff is that but there's this
kind of name uh Julie rapper Paul
um and she's head of film creation of
film creative and strategy
she used to work at the Weinstein
Company so she's really good at like
self-defense moves of bloke stopping
bloke
she's a ninja at it no she's really good
um saying no
um but her job basically is to find new
projects work on the development
this is what I think we need to do and
Jennifer salkin May sign off on this
stuff
Julia Rappaport is the person that is
probably going to be most involved day
to day actively in what Stargate then
looks like
not Jennifer salking
so we should tweet Julie Rapaport we
need to chase her down
um so
um but yeah she was with the heinzing
course she's not she's been promoted
actually through the Amazon ranks in the
last couple of years since the mpm
acquisition in particular when um they
took on MGM and obviously the two
Executives that were in charge there
that then went over to Warner Brothers
whose names have just come out my head
uh I know exactly who you're talking
about I did the whole Library
and some of Pam De Luca uh
and I uh is it Pam Abdi and John DeLuca
yes okay see I nearly got that right
um you know it's it's better when it's
like a consecutive a correlative brain
fart then we we can help each other yeah
um Mike Hopkins
but they're not gonna suck her because
she's doing great so they're not gonna
sucker
um at the end of the day well I say that
it's it's cons it's you know it's
it's a bit hard to say whether she's
doing great but the end of the day
Amazon Prime is the second biggest
streaming service in the world right now
Disney haven't overtaken them
um Josh no there's not there's not much
in it but Disney haven't overtaken him
and they're not that far behind Netflix
so you could argue and and it is
continuing to grow and Disney shrank a
little bit in the last quarter Amazon
continues to grow uh mainly because
they're pushing into new markets like
India and not China and other places so
they're becoming global
um but while it continues to grow
she's doing her job they they don't care
if rings of power is any good or not if
it brings in more subscribers at this
point yeah
it's still amazing that what was it 33
or 34 of people only finished it that
began at uh range of power which just
blows my mind you think at least half
would finish it but
good season two it'll bring back right
stormy will be like heralding it in oh
stormy left season one he loves it it's
great and there are events of it that
are but
I will go into season two with an open
mind I think they pick up the pace they
um
I I do think it's with rings of power
and I think it's maybe is a little bit
unfair
um is any Big Show like this they are
they do tend to be a little boring at
the beginning because they're
introducing all these characters and a
show like rings of powers there's lots
of characters to introduce
um and lots of like a bit of foundation
they have to lay a bit of story they
have to tell like the wisest person here
why is that because you know there's a
lot of chess pieces being moved yeah
it's quite hard to make that interesting
but you've got to do it you know yeah
there's a lot of
who's this guy why is he there
um and it's and then they can get onto
the swords
um I really like their cast I think
they've casted very well and all the
cast really likes like talking Source
material which I appreciate a lot yeah
that writing needs to do a little better
though
just some of the way I could do a little
better
um as long as we're not doing Rue
Goldbergs to make freaking Mordor
yeah we'll be okay they've also there's
always going to be terrible writing in
movies and TV series
um but yeah so the background is done
now surely they can crack on and get all
the second season so I think I do think
that's maybe a fair a fair assessment
yeah
the second season is important it's like
that big second album of a new band or
something the second season let's see
what they do
um but yeah this so there's Julia Robert
um she's going to be the woman that's in
charge of things like who do they talk
to about setting up the new show who uh
where would it be filmed
um
talking to the creators and making sure
that they're actually going into
directions and want them to go in
Jennifer sarki is not going to be
involved in those conversations yeah
yeah no not day to day they'll have
meetings in Jennifer saki if she's a
decent leader she's going to want to
know where things are going and where
things are you know what these videos
are doing particularly if they're
filming it they're making it
it's Julia rapporte report
um that actually if if any show like
this goes sideways if it's been made in
the last two years by Amazon that that's
the name you should be looking at not
not Jennifer not to let Jennifer get off
she's still the boss if they do
something that [__]
it's still kind of her fault yeah she's
going to sign off on it yeah yeah but
I'm just trying to say that there's more
there's a bigger team there and actually
really it's Mike hopkins's fault because
he's the boss
and like I say he's the one that
absolutely slammed MGM these you know
well it's good to get like get start
knowing these companies because you know
I I guess we have certain Netflix names
we know obviously we know half the
people that are running Disney in
different places just because we all
have grown up with Disney over time uh I
I you know I I don't know as many AMC or
comcast people as I feel like I should
but
especially now it's pretty pertinent to
start just getting getting comfortable
and getting uncomfortable with all the
studio Executives and knowing who's who
kind of who's saying what and and and
and what their prerogative is for their
companies you know yeah
is there a local common denominator
between sci-fi fans and denizens and
Dragons players I mean how many
subscribe to both just out of Interest
sci-fi fans how many of you also have
done since Dragon fans
um I I've never done dungeons I've never
done DND me either right um but I would
argue but yeah I kind of want to
um but I would argue that it's about
fantasies and it's about telling stories
it's about you know immersing yourself
in a world so yeah I think sci-fi fans
and fantasy fans and fans have done some
dragons like that 100 I'm too lazy I
think my main problem is I don't have
the passion for it but I do think
they'll be a strong denominator yeah
I think all the people that enjoyed
sci-fi probably like guns and dragons
and vice versa or are appreciate it at
least
um
problem is rings of power is bad for
casting to stories they think they can
do better than talking themself and the
political agenda and Tolkien should
never be connected in any case
never just for Devil's advocacy I don't
think they ever said they're going to do
I'd find me where someone said they're
going to do better than Tolkien and then
I'm with you but I don't think the
casting was bad uh yes there's some
diversity stuff but like that's it's
just
talk about sci-fi put it in there make
it natural they didn't really the wrong
team was pretty bad yeah but they didn't
shove I guess any of that down your
throat I guess so I I didn't have a
problem with that at the end of the day
I actually really liked the cast I think
they're very
um I can't think of any of the cast I
didn't yeah like it's just the writing
for me really
yeah
um and and the politics
Tolkien story was political it was
written at the end of World War II World
War One World of one one
um
the whole point of the Rings of power
was countries coming together
against an enemy
it was not subtly
seeped in
in you know a political storyline
um I think the agenda is to uh
correctly if I'm wrong but I think the
agenda you're talking about is maybe
some of the um you know that we had
um
elves of color and things like this and
I get that I don't know the right way to
say that nowadays but um
anyway let's just skip over it which I
didn't say so um see even me I'm worried
about getting into trouble with these
things
[Music]
Henry's character in that who I didn't
think was very good either I love Lenny
Henry he's great but his character that
but that race of
um Harford half what's supposed to be
darker in skin that's actually in
Tolkien so I mean
yeah yes and no I
I think the political agenda was
something that was driven a lot by
YouTube channels shouting about it I
don't think it was legitimately there I
really don't and and if it were there I
would call it out but
I don't remember
now the bad writing smash you in the
face a couple times
but I don't I don't think anything uh on
the that type of surface level does
anything like that
yeah I mean I I've been watching the
second series of Picard
and at one point
uh Rafi and seven of nine just sort of
stop and they make there's some riots
famous riots in the Star Trek universe
um and they just literally stop and go
racism bad in it oh it's terrible at
this time and literally the story just
stops for like 45 seconds and they make
a a comment about racism and the race
um equality in America at this time and
you know the you know the the separation
in a lot of America that it's you know
um
it's it was so I was so badly done it
was it was literally like the stories
going the story's going stories going oh
race is bad and then story's going story
going straight and then it was so
obvious it's so clear that there's an
agenda to that point in the story that
you just want to go oh [__] sake
there's better ways to it's like the one
of the things the Sci-Fi I found I'm
gonna go around now one of the things
with sci-fi and fantasy is that you can
say these things you can talk about race
you can talk about sex you can talk
about transgender issues and all these
things without having to talk about it
because it's a metaphor it's a simile
it's a thing you can educate people
without shoving it down their throats
you can you know you can talk about
things that you can't talk about
otherwise in you know upsetting people
because you use metaphor and naturally
tends to fit in the narratives as well
it's not like
pigeonholed somewhere it's it's it's
there it feels natural which is kind of
a good way to do things typically make
it feel natural make it feel lived in
and not
in in your face down your throat
whatever you want to say because that's
yeah without lecturing you don't need to
lecture people because you but also you
can tell both sides
of the story you can you can you know
you can do that if you're talking about
I don't know
the transgender issue at the moment
isn't just about rights there isn't
there isn't a mental health element of
it there as well that people don't talk
about that you could talk about in
metaphor without upsetting anyone within
sci-fi without upsetting anyone without
trampling anyone's rights
um or anything of this sort of thing you
but you can talk about it more openly
because you're not really talking about
it you know what I mean there's layers
to it and that's the point and yeah
without lecturing people
um and that's you know
I don't agree that we need to leave the
woke crap out of but I want sci-fi to be
I I've made this argument a few times I
always lose subscribers over it so get
ready but I want sci-fi to be awake I
wanted to talk about things that are
important I wanted to talk about sexism
racism transunions and everything
I just don't want it to be before the
story
I want the story to be about these
things and I want them to be
entertaining still and I want to come
away and think that's interesting and
let me think about stuff
I mean but the writing's got to be good
enough that it's not
you know shove down your throat yeah and
it doesn't even necessarily have to be
like a weight per se it just sci-fi is
so conceptual that like hey if we can
talk about time doing this this and this
I'm pretty sure we can we can fit
something else in here fairly easily
without you know
heavy-handing it or something like that
it's I don't know I I I I a sci-fi
horror and fantasy are those three
genres that I think are way ahead of
their time 100 of the time and I I
think you just had to look to those and
look to the best of those three genres
to find the right way to do those things
well they have the Elven that is the um
the black fellow it was the Elven who's
the main story
yeah
Ismail Cruz Cordova is his name
um he's brilliant in it um but I I do
think that was the one bit they went too
far I think you could have had colored
dwarfs call it you know the half foots
were fine and all that thing but the
Elven
will always sort of supposed to be like
Nordic so I think that was a step too
far I do think they were thinking
diversity there and I think they they
would have done a lot better if they'd
have not done that
himself though it's not him trying to go
Herald in something he's going for a
paycheck and he he's a really good elf I
think he's probably the best elf we've
seen so far just portrayed wise uh but
it doesn't necessarily fit into the
books Eastern humans and dwarves and
things like that and talking yes uh
there is end Universe explanations but
he just made me laugh to unsubscribe
unsubscribe unsubscribe Jay may have
said something I kind of disagree with
or maybe not I'm trying to be about it
um that might be the best comment of the
day
um I must start giving giving like I
need to start like giving an award for
the best Goblin to the day I was
literally just thinking that I was like
that might be a good thing to start
doing when do you at the end that's how
we end our videos
um but yeah but I was just thinking you
know there's so many
um I'm gonna go watch him
Mission Impossible shortly so I'm gonna
have to go in very in a couple of
minutes did you not watch at the end of
the day watch this tonight got tickets
no I'm not I'm watching it tomorrow I'm
watching tomorrow that's why we're late
tomorrow I'm not going out I'm going out
to dinner tonight that's right okay
so I've got to go get dressed up because
I've promised the wife we've got no kids
so I promise the wife I'll take that and
get dressed up
I'm gonna get dressed up we're gonna
make it there's some romantic evening of
it and then tomorrow we're gonna go
watch Mission Impossible
um that's why we're starting at half
five tomorrow not five because I'm gonna
get in I think I'm gonna walk in the
door at like five o'clock
because it's like a three hour film it
starts at half one I'm like
yeah so um you have to run like Tom
Cruise to your computer yeah we were
talking me and my wife watched The
Fallout yesterday we were talking about
people running
and we are live tomorrow we will be live
at 5 30. I'm hoping it's gonna be the
full team we are talking about we're
going to do a little series now unlike
um strike survival and how are we going
to survive the strike
um I'm doing a health and safety Guy
video but I'm then I might do a um I am
doing a survival expert surviving the um
the strike as well there's a bit of a
pistake
um but yeah so we're doing the we're
gonna pick 10 shows that you've got to
binge when we get to the point where we
stop getting new stuff which will be
soon
so a romantic evening in Telford
yeah pretty much I'm not telling you
where I'm going though in case all the
fans turn up and mop me
I'm getting like
people outside the windows with Side
Tracks like this
brass getting thrown at me and oh what
what what's the romantic movie with with
Andrew Lincoln and isn't Colin Firth in
there too it's the Christmas movie with
all the signs that they're holding up
just go go bug them with a bunch of
signs if you're in Telford just go go
make them in a Romance movie or
something
I I generally generally thought about
half our audience in America so I went
over to New York at Christmas and I
genuinely thought I didn't genuinely
think but I was obviously thinking I'll
get there'll be some sort of party when
I arrive right
I'm very very popular in America
um so I've cracked
do you know what parts of America
because obviously we got a Canadian part
of Sidetrack so Canada
yeah we have a strong Canadian
um push which is amazing um
third most highly populated country on
the planet so and we've got
twelve thousand subscribers over there
or something like that so I I just
thought it would be like the beat when
the Beatles landed I just I just thought
that's what I was gonna get but it was
just it wasn't well if that's the case
which Beetle are you
[Music]
um
your Ringo
yeah because I'm not good enough looking
to be here
I'm the pudding in the back
you can be up front lead guitar I'm
going to be putting in the back see I
who's your favorite beetle is my
question real fast
well did you listen to any of his solo
work I think that just proves that so
fast I'm sorry but also a lot of Joko
McCartney wrote some of the best songs
to be fair uh I think McCartney is
probably the most overall talented
Beetle I think Lennon kind of lucked out
in a lot of ways but my favorite George
Harrison I think he's got the prettiest
voice I he he's the most I think raw
talent I guess just feels like natural
he never tries to make a show out of it
he's just having a good time
yeah yeah uh he was yeah he was talented
now I'm currently I'm gonna go mcconnie
and McCartney did that frogs song
well and and that and then he still
holds I think the most bought Song Ever
from not the Beatles uh in the UK at
least as I think it's Paul McCartney and
Wings still it's mull of uh kintyre I
think is still the most spot song and uh
the UK ever I'll look up
um
Elton John with the Candle in the Wind
oh that's gotta be up there it was the
most um bought almost played song
uh just for that but anyway anyway
Stargate let's go back to end five
minutes five minutes blend
um what
right so I mean just like
is it fair to say Amazon are going to
ruin star game or is it more fair to say
Amazon
will pick people and throw money at them
that may or may not ruin
Target
the ladder yeah I mean because that's
the way Amazon do it it's not that's
that's the way you know I think it's
when most production companies do it
though isn't it I mean I think Disney
they seem to tell
creators what sort of show they want yes
consensus isn't it that they say
you know we want this show and we wanted
to fit these demographics and things
Amazon don't seem to do that
I don't seem to
[Music]
um
You could argue with rings of power okay
they they said look we can't you can't
just have a bunch of white blonde haired
elves we gotta we gotta mix this up that
could have come from Amazon that could
have come from the creators though just
as easy remembering that creators are
creative a lot of them are hippies
you know and they you know they do try
to they do want to put
you know they do try to put their
agendas in their writing because they've
always done it I think Executives do
that particularly I think executives are
more interested in like who stars in it
and how it's advertise things that seems
to be more Executives and they're very
interesting how much they're costing
yes I think that's typically the thing
but they do want those boxes ticked a
lot of times at the same time yeah
and I think that that's their only
concern is like as long as the box is
ticked do what you feel like and we'll
give you some money as long as it's not
going to make a bunch of people angry at
us
so I have to explain the boys which
really doesn't tick many books it ticks
every box the boy is the boys is maybe
the wokeish wokeest show quote unquote
on television and it's still great it it
fits every woke thing that you can think
about tenfold I mean it's anti-anything
I mean just look at the way they portray
Homeland or anything like that it's very
much like anti-rightwings
right wing and the good guys are very
much left-wing yes yeah I mean yeah I
can see that that it's it's actually but
it's subtle because it's behind a wall
of
getting people crushed heads and Gore
and stuff but um and it's still great I
mean I'm a Texas boy and I'm I'm I know
a lot of people raised around me that uh
would not typically like that kind of
stuff but they still love the boys
because it's just that entertaining you
know
yeah
um you know yeah you're saying SGU I I
I'm gonna do a video about SGU and I'm
gonna argue
I I have to ask Brad right if it's okay
first
because I don't want to piss him off
again
um but I actually think SGU was ruined
by
um a plan to do something different and
the they went into it saying we've got
to do something different instead of
instead of it like naturally evolving
that they were thinking let's do
something different
you know
they
were being evacuated what sorry boys are
Star Trek I think I think it's the fires
are they still going on in Canada
oh crap yeah I didn't even think about
that and she said and I was like [__] I
was like be safe literally yeah Carrie
dropped me a line we just want to make
sure you're all right okay we look after
each other so drop us a drop us a line
please
um
so yeah I can't remember what I'm saying
so that's like through me but um but
yeah our SGU quote unquote could have
ruined Stargate and I just think we're
just are we by ruining Stargate I think
are we just gonna get something that
people don't watch
and that's that's it is it is it gonna
kill be gonna get killed I don't care if
this is
well I do care if it's work crap
obviously
um but I don't care if they have every
demographic call I don't care if they
have a blue gay disabled
transgender
um
Smurf in the character list I don't know
um I I got a bit I gotta I start losing
forgetting demographics towards the end
I don't care if they've got characters
that tick every box I don't care if
those characters are well written they
go on cool adventures and you know
there's stories that I don't have to
like every episode
but if there's enough episodes there to
keep me engaged
great I'm really liking strange new
Worlds at the moment hated the first two
episodes but I'm I'm getting into it now
the series is getting me going it's got
me
that's what's important you know that's
it's got to be a show that I come to the
end of it and I go yeah I can't wait for
the next one
you know and and I I I hope this doesn't
play Under the SG ruin Stargate things
but I think SGU did all of that right
like and they didn't ever like shove it
down your throats or anything I think
Camille Ray
character is one of the probably most I
guess relatable and easiest lesbian
characters that I've seen portrayed on
TV and that was before like it was
popular to do so you know it was just
kind of
hey this is part of the show and then
you can like it or not we're not going
to make it too heavy-handed but the
parts that you watch you're gonna feel
for like you're going to be put in her
life and then feel it and I think they
did really well with that and all other
kind of little boxes in there you know
yeah but that's how you do it without
truly ticking boxes
most underrepresented what about
Smurfette
she's the only one that's the point oh
really do you really need an email Smith
um this is sort of all the smurfs of
boys except for Smurfette and she was
like oh I'm gonna try to remember now
whether she was created I think it was
it wasn't it um it was the bad guy
trying to
create a Smurf for some reason to take
her because he's trying to get the power
in but he did it by accident he created
Smith by mistake and I think that's
right
um
yeah SGU I I honestly think hdu didn't
run MGM ruined Stargate because they ran
out of money I think that was the point
and that's when I'm gonna make a point
in my video when I do it if I ever get
around to it is the SGU I don't think
the writers quite knew how to do what
they were planning to do and I don't
think Brad Wright quite knew how to make
the show he wanted to make
but by the end of season one he did
and you know there's a subtle difference
between what they've been doing and what
they wanted to do and it took them a
series to get like grips of that
that's every series pretty much ever
that's different Captain caveman's done
it again Captain okay hey man that's the
only thing
I'm not a big fan of Stargate of the
movie if the new Star game is worse than
that it will be a flop
I struggle to watch the move you know
after me now I do I loved it when it
came out but I do struggle to watch it
now because I'm just like that's
different that's different it's not as
good as a series um
no I just said which is just weird
because I feel the same way but I don't
often find myself liking
I I love Michael shakes and RDA but you
wouldn't think that you would like their
performances more than Kurt Russell and
James Spader but I do at the end of the
day I love them and I don't feel like
Kurt Russell and James Spader bring what
they bring to the role it's interesting
I was thinking that when I did it that's
my last Captain Caveman
I need to step away from the speaker or
something if I do put my hand over the
speaker or something I don't have great
uh I shouldn't really go too close to
the speaker
did that goes sexy that was very sensual
very quickly I don't have any microphone
knowledge or how to do it
ASMR over here
huh it's a j ASMR so it'd be like jsmr
there you go yeah there you go you got
your new I finally to go like Facebook
radio
ASMR Stargate hey I was just saying the
other day I I I I tweeted it I sent it
to Matt because I was like maybe Matt
would enjoy this kind of stuff
I I was like I like to put like Lo-Fi on
in the background while I'm trying to
write while I'm trying to do something
if I'm just like doing some yard work or
something like that you know
it was it was a good one uh
but there's no there's no Stargate Lo-Fi
there's no like there's a couple like
ambient beats and stuff and things like
that but no one's really tapped into the
Stargate Lo-Fi and there's so much that
you could do with all the soundtracks
we've already been getting the scores
we've been given someone's got to do it
yes I write it's a microphone not a
speaker here's the one thing with the
internet everyone points out your
mistakes so quickly yeah
thank you Daisy
there will be free
um I'm excited I generally like to uh
make mistakes just because it repeats
people
um
yeah I'm getting lots of my Mrs now yeah
um I definitely haven't enjoyed star
game made for movies and the rhyme of
the show was over yeah they remind the
show's over I took it uh Continuum
wasn't my favorite
I didn't love it
um Arc of truth I loved you know but um
but yeah I didn't I didn't love continue
I wish we'd send the next few next few
are going to be amazing
I I liked what they were I just I I wish
they would have acknowledged more that
like this was the end I I feel like it
would have been it would have felt
better if it was
true
roasting but but I I don't know those TV
movies they're they're not all that
great but they're they're fun I do enjoy
them for what they are I just feel like
if they if they would have allowed it to
be the end of a chapter
it would have been really cool and that
would have been a really good way to end
some stuff
well that I mean the Arc of truth I mean
I love that one but it's like it is a
double episode
yeah
Continuum trying to be a bit more of a
movie and you know what I can't actually
remember that movie is about it's time
travel isn't it yeah yes I remember the
start really well
I watched it a couple months ago and
really all I remember from it is Cameron
Mitchell running around old cam uh he's
a big part of it I think that's really
where he shined the most or was allowed
to shine the most yep
and understand with um please continue
isn't it Richie nunson and ball let's
stop
or is that one of the episode was that
one of the later episodes of the series
that's what I'm trying to remember
because there's like the last episode
that involves time as well and sg1 and
then well I've got a few of the DVDs
I've not thought about that for a while
because
um I I can't I can't remember so um but
but you know Arc of Truth is one of
those ones I've watched a few times and
I've watched you read because I really
enjoyed it I just wish we'd got a
Atlantis movie that they were planning
because it would have been incredible
please also I don't think popcorn power
realizes that the guy that played ball
passed away I wish we could bring him
back too
um it's just a likable actor just such a
like he was great he was great there's a
reason why he's one of the most popular
villains
anyway right I'm going to go and I'm
going to go and romance my wife and do
the uh do the sexy voice thing right
into this speaker
um you know we want to do
um uh we will be live tomorrow guys
we're going to be talking about those
din binge-worthy TV shows I've also got
a couple of other things I want to talk
to you about I'm hoping my internet will
be a little bit better than it is at the
moment
um and anyway we're gonna do we're
really gonna
you know take the piss as we always do
Max should be back
I've got a long list of videos that are
coming in the next couple of weeks
just to quickly show you
half of them are Futurama videos don't
worry
plus that's the list no you can't you
can't think that's a list of the videos
that I've got coming up
um
and you know work on that me and you are
doing a h archive video which should be
fun we're going to try and do that
tomorrow
um and yeah just we've had a lot of fun
and I will do more of these live videos
or I just come on and I'll just talk and
hopefully some of you will listen I
don't think we answered the question on
where the Stargate will be ruined by by
Amazon or not but maybe we did because
we don't think
I don't think it'll be Amazon to ruin it
I think it'll be who they pick to run it
that they'll either ruin it or not
um
I just I know some big exact isn't too
involved because it's when they have
um I think Amazon just do let people get
on with it once they've decided who's
gonna do it they just trust them and
they'll get on with it so they just need
to just trust the right people Mark
Fergus and Hawkins be to develop this
show and then get a showrunner in that
respects what they're doing do you think
they're going to continue to do that
though do you think they're going to
continue to like let people have as much
free reign as they have even after rings
of power
it's a good question it's not even just
after rings of power it's that now
they've started to do more of their own
stuff they actually have their own
Studios now they have this relationship
with that group that owned studio space
all over the world which I'm again I'm
going to be talking about more the
Hackman group
um that means they're going to be able
to make more of their own stuff and if
they're making more of their own stuff
I would be more involved in making that
stuff you know Sony have a big part of
what the boys is
yeah yeah
even rings of power there were other
companies involved in that the expanse
it was the company called amicron that
actually produced it Amazon just bought
it
so you can argue lots of these shows
were ruined by Amazon whereas Amazon
really just funded it
yeah they just thought it was something
to buy
um
so now I think the next 10 years is when
we will figure out what Amazon actually
about
and how good a company they can be as
they start to grow up and mature into a
actual Studio
instead of a bank
we keep talking about like what's AI
going to look like in 10 years what are
jobs going to look like in 10 years all
these things what the hell are these
Studios gonna look like in 10 years is
another good question because you know
the existing Studios might be gone
that's what I'm saying like Disney might
be bought out by Apple a couple people
might be bought out by Apple Comcast
might just be like all right now we're
gonna expand things again uh and kind of
take back hold of something they've lost
over time not really lost they're still
huge but you know what I would honestly
think about Apple in the next five years
don't be shocked if they buy Paramount
people keep talking about Disney I think
Apple might buy Paramount first I think
it fits better with their repertoire of
what they have too Apple can't afford
Disney
Disney's too big it's too diverse they
they will always fall back on other
elements to their business I know
they're losing a shitload of money at
the moment but they they will always
fall back on different parts and they
they will be all right if if they can
write the ship don't get me wrong they
do another 10 years like the last 10
years they'll be in trouble
I I worry that Bob iger's gonna leave
and sell everything but I don't think
he'll sell the parks I think they might
do a 21st century uh Fox kind of deal
where 21st Century Fox sold 21st Century
Fox but they kept Fox Sports they kept
Fox News uh they kept Fox Business and a
couple other little smaller things like
that
I wouldn't be surprised if Disney was
like okay first off get ESPN out of here
second off sale Disney Plus sell Disney
as like a as a company but don't sell
its Parks don't sell the thing that can
continues to make the Disney family
money I guess yeah we're the
shareholders and stuff yeah I pulled
through loads of sci-fi
on us that's that's one of the things
they do the most of is sci-fi
um so
no I disagree with you on that one see
yeah
I thought I misread it but no Apple's
way sci-fi Paramount's not as much
sci-fi but they still have some sci-fi
Star Trek is their biggest thing
um I I'm loving Paramount listen though
which I think it's got some great
selling on it I think pound per pound it
might be the best streaming service
besides Apple I think Apple probably
pound per pound is the best but
Paramount's right up there which I think
fits better just imagine how like apple
quality show tossed onto like Halo or
something that'd be great yeah
um but yeah like I said that um secular
monk says Disney's net worth is 157
billion apples is 300 3 trillion so yeah
don't get me wrong they would but
what I'm trying to say is from a
business model Disney is pretty secure
because it's got
lots of different aspects to its
business that it can rely on Paramount
doesn't Paramount has a brilliant
archive which Apple desperately want
they have and they're an actual
established Studio which Apple
desperately want to remember that Apple
tried to buy
um MGM but around a bit
um so Apple would be in the market of
Paramount has another 12 months like
it's just had
they could go they could be available
potentially for a takeover event lasting
but Disney is
um
but as I said give them another 10 give
them another 10 years like they've just
had
and then it'll be a different story oh
yeah and I think Disney in the next
four to five years we will see Disney
sell
and streamline their business in certain
areas I think they will well we've
already started to see it with their
syndicating of of their stuff which they
promised they wouldn't do and here we
are five six seven years later yep uh
just just with the Apple Paramount
thought super fast if Apple would buy
out Paramount do they keep the name
ample plus TV or do they put it all on
Paramount plus and and kind of Herald in
like oh we are part of an old studio now
kind of deal I think they should do
something a little bit like what I'm
gonna I always thought Disney should
have done this more they should have a
Fox channel on Disney plus but they have
that stars Channel which is kind of kind
of their Fox channel I think that's what
the Apple would do I think they would
have a channel within this show but
within that but don't do what you know
um
um Amazon do and have like page channels
within the channel but if I would say I
would merge them because that's Apple
TV's biggest problems there's not enough
um so I would merge them
and I'd streamline it and I would um and
I would also do something that Netflix
are quite good at and I would rotate
stuff all the time so I would take I
would have shows on there just for like
six months then I'd take them off for a
bit and then I bring them back after a
couple of years and I do things like
that because it's cheaper to run because
I'm a service base
interesting for the consumer
um and Netflix are quite good at that
they bring stuff off get rid of it too
so far
yeah have a bit of a cycle too I think
that's one things Disney have failed at
is they don't do that they have too much
of their big stuff on there they don't
take it off
and we're too used to as well as I think
as soon as a film comes out within four
or five months it's on Disney Plus or
even quicker than that if it's not done
very well at the cinema
fair to compare Disney plus to a library
and a lot of these other places is a
bookstore
yeah yeah and that and that's a that's a
shame really
it was the foot Julie has it it was the
four guys on about yes thank you I love
the folder my wife bought me the full
set on TV a couple years ago
um but but yeah um
but yeah I could I could I could see
that and I could see Apple trying to
bring it together under one umbrella
that they'll then probably charge more
like Netflix money for because at the
moment Apple here anyway is nearly half
the price of of Netflix oh yeah um and
Disney but because there isn't enough on
it to Warrant it and Disney Apple run it
at a loss but they don't mind
um
whereas obviously if they had more on it
they could charge more
yeah no that makes sense
Netflix is one of those I'm sorry
Apple's definitely one of those things
you should just get for a month and then
turn it off for like six months and then
just put it back on and binge shots on
there for a month you know something
like
I I still need to do my phone oh you
know what I should go ahead and do that
today uh renew my
Hulu this is so interesting the Hulu
thing so Honolulu is part owned it's
part is it uh Universal Comcast and
Universal so they have so they basically
own it between the two um but Disney
still and I think Disney own about 70 of
it
um and then Conquest on anything and
there's a deal in place at the moment
they're gonna buy the other 30
about 20 billion I think is was about
right but this agreement was a year ago
and then things have changed and now
Disney's trying to get out of it are
they one that they're trying to
renegotiate the money
they want to pay less for it or get out
of it altogether
and and I think that would probably be a
very good idea and all of a sudden
Disney do not have
liquid asset to to go for the deal but
obviously Comcast to go in you sign the
contract
so there's a potentially a massive Court
battle on the way
so
I may be mistaken but there's a way for
them to sell everything to Comcast as
well right
but the current agreement is the other
way it's Disney
in principle to buy and there's a price
but they said they were going to do it
this year and I think it's in the next
couple of months it's supposed to be
done so yeah we were coming up on it
yeah yeah so yeah well that'll be
interesting to see what happens there
whether concastle
um basically force it which it could do
or whether they will come up with some
sort of deal but um it turns out rigid
and how flexible the contract was with
isn't it so there's lots to talk about
but anyway guys
Harris thank you so much for jumping on
me of course of course
um fascinating conversation I'm going to
let's say I'm going to start doing this
a little bit more often and um we'll um
just get together and have a bit of a
chin wagon
and you guys can have your opinions as
well which I think is great so yeah
thank you so so much
um we will see you tomorrow at half five
yeah in the meantime
stay good guys we'll see you soon it's
Foundation time
oh we're gonna watch foundation in yeah
you just reminded me to get my Apple
thing back I might as well go do that
real quick well I watched the first
episode of foundation realized I have no
freaking clue what's going on I'm about
to go back and start watching the first
series again
did not give you a good recap
no
not to do a YouTube recap okay anyway
see you later guys bye-bye everybody
foreign
[Music]